على كل من القاهره ينضم لنا المحامي
بالنقطه المستشار على مصطفى وعبر الهاتف
تنضم الينا العضوه في مجلس النواب النائب
رانيا الجزائري التي تطالب باعاده النظر
في نظام المجلس الحسبي اهلا بكم ما ابدا
معك مستشار علاء اولا ما رايك بالجدل
الكبير حول وضع المراه او الام الارمله في
مصر ومطالبات بالغاء نظام المجلس الحسبي
اهلا وسهلا بحضرتك
بخصوص الموضوع المصار حاليا تحت مسمى تحت
الوصايا وفي المسلسل اللي هو بيصير يعني
هو مش جديد قبل كده احنا الموضوع ده من
حوالي سنه او سنه ونصف تحت بند او تحت
مسمى هاشتاج الولايه حقي تم اطلاق هذه
الحمله بتاعه الولايه حق عشان ينقلوا
الولايه الماليه او الولايه على مال
الصغير الى الام الارمله او الام المطلقه
فالموضوع مش جديد هو كل الحكايه ان
المسلسل او الهاشتاق اللي اتعمل ما جابش
نتيجه فعاله او عايزين يبقى خلي الموضوع
له تاثير اكثر في الميديا او تاثير اكثر
على الافراد الشعب فعملوا من خلال مسلسل
يطرح قدام الناس مشكله كبيره مش مشكله لان
القانونيه اولا نود ان نعرف انت شو رايك
بالقانون
لا طبعا ما فيش حاجه اسمها ننقل كامل
الوصاي او كامل الولايه للام او للارمله
ما فيش رقيب لان الضمانه الاساسيه في وجود
التصرف في مال الصغير ان يكون في حد تاني
رقيب على هذا المال وخلي بالي حضرتك
الجد او الجد الجد الاب او العم ما بيبقاش
حر في مطلق التصرف المالي بتاع الصغير لا
ده بيبقى تحت مصايد المجلس الحزبي يعني كل
تصرف بيعمله او كل حاجه بيعملها في المال
محل الحفظ بيكون تحت وصايه المجلس الحاسبي
خلينا خلينا نسمع وجهه نظر اخرى استاذه
رانيا اهلا بك معنا في مسائل عربيه هل من
تبرير لان يتحكم العم الجد بابناء شخص
متوفى بدلا من ان تعتني بهذه الاموال
المراه الارمله وتعين بها نفسها وابنائها
بالضبط كده يعني انا طبعا برحب بحضرتك
وبرحب
بالمحامي الفاضل اللي مع حضرتك هو بس
النظريه ان العام او
الجد اولى من الام
بالوصايا ممكن اعرف السبب ايه هل ده معناه
ان المراه ناقصه اهليه مثلا او مش تحمل
مسؤوليه ولادها او ان هي مش امينه لا
تؤتمن على مال ولادها اذا كان اذا كان
معلش الام مؤتمن على تربيه اولادها
الارواح فاحنا بنيجي على المال اللي هو
ابسط حاجه ونقلنا منها هل ده انتقاص من
شان المراه
وده اللي انا بساله المحامي اللي مع حضرتك
وفي نفس الوقت ان احنا في الزمن اللي احنا
فيه قاده سياسيه بتحمل كل معاني الاحترام
والتقدير والاجلال للمراه المصريه
وبتحاول ان هي تتشتى المجالات ان تدي
المراه المصريه حقوقها وقدرها في انها
تتولى جميع المناصب دلوقتي في عندنا في
مصر معظم المناطق لم يكن جميعها المراه
لها الحق انها تتولاها فده يعني ده اكبر
اثبات ان المراه مؤهله طب سيده رانيا
خلوني انقل هالفكره خليني انقلها للسيده
علاء طيب السيد علاء لماذا تؤول الوصايه
الماليه للجد ثم العام لماذا لا تقول الام
ما دام انه الام هي اللي تعتني وهي اللي
تربي اولادها
لان الولايه في الاصل جايه من الشريعه
الاسلاميه حضرتك احنا القوانين اللي عندنا
الخمس قوانين اللي بيتم العبث فيهم او
اللعب فيهم اللي هو قانون الولائي على
المياه القانون الولايه على على النفس
قوانين الاحوال الشخصيه قانون المواريث
لائحه المؤذنين الحاجات دي كلها جايه من
الشريعه الاسلاميه يعني الشريعه الاسلاميه
بنستمد القوانين دي من الشريعه الاسلاميه
حضرتك ما ينفعش الولايه اللي هي اصلا
للعصب تنتقل للام احنا بنقول حفظ الصغير
طبقا للحضانه بيبقى للام لكن حفظ المال
بيبقى للعصب لانه هو الاولى بالرعايه على
الصغير في ماله دي رقم واحد رقم اتنين ده
ليس انتقاصا من حق المراه في النهايه
تتربي اطفالها او تصرف عليهم وفي نقطه
ثانيه مهمه جدا المسلسل ما تعرضش ليها ان
في تعميم من البنك المركزي ان يجوز
للامهات الحاضنات او يجوز للامهات
المطلقات او يجوز للامهات الارامل ان هم
يفتحوا حسابات طبقا للماده ثلاثه من
القانون 119 لسنه 52 يفتحوا حسابات في
البنوك
لابنائهم ويصرف ده موجود ولكن من يضمن لها
حقها من يضمن حق امراه ارمله
المجلس الحزبي يا فندم المجلس الحاسبي
المجلس الحزبي هو الرقيب على تصرفات
الوالي او تصرفات القيم على الصغير او
الوسخ على الصغير في حاجه ثانيه مهمه
القانون 176 لسنه 2020 حضرتك هما عارفين
طبعا هم عدلوا كان الاول في 1000 جنيه حد
اقصى للصرف على الصغير ثم سنه لحد ادنى ثم
3000 جنيه تم تعديله من خمسه الى 10000
جنيه
وتقديم طلب للمحامي العام بطلب مسبب اذا
كان في حاله كوارث او او مرض او عمليات او
حادثه يزداد المبلغ ل 20,000 جنيه ففي
تعديلات تمت على هذا القانون لكن اللي
احنا نشيل موضوع الولايه من من الرجل او
من الود اللي هو الجد الشرعي اللي هو
الولايه الشرعيه بعد الاب او بعد تعيين
بهذا تعيين الجد نديها للام لا ده فيها
يعني احنا بنقول الضمانه الاساسيه لحفظ
هذا المال بتروح نخلي السيده رانيا سيده
رانيا ما رايك بالحجج القانونيه التي
استند اليها السيده طبعا اول حاجه هقولها
ان احنا لنا كامل الاحترام للنيابه طبعا
والقضاء ان هم بيحاولوا ان هم يساعدوا في
حفظ مال الايتام لكن في نفس الوقت انا ليا
تحافظ على اللي حضرتك بيقولوا ان هو ده
الشريعه ممكن تجيب لي حاجه في القران
الكريم بتقول ان المراه
عصب ان هو لازم يتولى الوصايه على ولاده
على على الايتام في القران الكريم مفيش
حاجه مني دي نمبر وان نمبر 2 يا فندم
موجود لا يا فندم موجود ده موجود انا ممكن
اكمل كلامي وبعدين ممكن نتكلم حضرتك ممكن
ترد عليا
موجود في القران الكريم
هاتلك حته افكار النقطه التانيه ان
غير
الشريعه الاسلاميه حضرتك بتقول ده ممكن
الناس نسال فيها الازهر وناخد رايهم هل
فعلا عندنا في القران الكريم حاجه بتقول
النص صريح انك بتقول ان الام ما تبقاش هي
وصيه على مال اولادها يا ريت حضرتك ناخذ
راي الازهر في النقطه دي النقطه الثانيه
ان انا الطلب بتاعي انا طالبه ان هو يكون
المجلس الحادي او الوصايه الحاسديه تبقى
اختياري بمعنى ان الزوج لو لقى ان مراته
لسبب من عدم تعليمها مثلا او ان هي قليله
الخبره او ان هي شايف الزوج ان ام اولاده
مش هتقدر تكون وصيه عليهم يعني بما يكفل
ان هي تحمي اموالهم او مصالحهم ساعتها
ممكن يتقاعد دم بالطلب في حياه عينه ليه
المجلس الحربي غير ان هو عايز من فضلكم
ان امر ولادي من بعدي لو حصل لي اي طرح
انا طالبه ان هو يكون انا غير انتقاص يعني
لا انتقص اطلاقا من طبعا دور المجلس
الحاسبي والساده القضاء وكلاء النيابه
اللي بيقوموا بالواجبهم على اكمل الوجه
لكن انا بتكلم في نقطه ان اولا فيها نقط
كتير انا ممكن اتحدث فيها في في المهانه
اللي بتتعرض لها الام في انها تروح المبنى
بتاع النيابه العامه مع المجرمين علشان
يعني
تتسول حقوق لاولادها ثاني حاجه
في الطوارئ الام ما بيبقاش معاها فلوس
انها تترك لعمليات او اي حاجه بتضطر انها
لازم تاخذ الاول موافقه علشان تعمل ابنها
عمليه وده الكلام ده واقع وحضرتك اكيد
عارف ثالث حاجه ما عندناش خبر كافيين
ينزلوا يدوروا على ال ال الممتلكات بتاعت
الولاد او ان هم يقدروها عشان يمشوا حتى
مصالح الولاد ده كل ده حمل زايد على
النيابه العامه
الكل يعني في نقط كثير ممكن نتكلم فيها بس
انا النقطه الاساسيه ان والله اللي شايف
ان زوجته عندها من يعني من من مثلا من قله
الخبره ان هي
خاصه باولاده بقى من بعده يكتب والله طلب
انه يبقى في وصايم المجلس لحد الى جانب ان
الوصايه التعليميه ما تنفعش
تروح لا يعني معلش كامله احترامي بقى سيبك
من الاموال انا بتكلم كمان في الوصايه
التعليميه ازاي انا يبقى ابني وانا مش
عارفه انقله مدرسه ما اقدرش ان انا اضرب
تعليمه ادرى مستواه وقدره ان انا
يعني
الموضوع وربما لا تكفي دقائق لنقاش لكن
الموضوع جدلي على كل حال
يا فندم الولايه التعليميه موجوده بموجب
الولايه التعليميه موجوده للحكوميه 126
موجوده لا يا فندم هي موجوده الولايه
الولايه التعليميه هي اصلا موجوده موجوده
دلوقتي في القانون 126 سنه 2008 ده من
2008 موجوده في القانون مش جديده لسه مش
لسه هنطلب تعليميه للام موجوده ولا
تعليميه للحاضنه
لان الولايه لان الولايه التعليميه جزء من
الولايه العامه الولايه العامه بتبقى للاب
او للجد الشرعي بعديه ديت ده جاي من
القرارات على النساء وللرجال
ليله تطالب في نظام مجلس حاسبي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات